hi I'm Beau broadbeck extension
specialist in community forestry and
Arbor culture with the Alabama
Cooperative Extension system today we're
going to review some basic chainsaw
safety considerations from ensuring your
saw is in working order to wearing the
proper safety gear
[Music]
while many of us own chainsaws and enjoy
their efficiency for cutting firewood or
removing debris after storms it's easy
to forget that if improperly operated
that can be extremely dangerous and even
life-threatening Begin by making sure
all the safety features on your saw are
present and in good working order second
make sure your saw is well maintained
ensure that the chain is sharp dual
chains decreased cutting efficiency and
make operators work harder check that
the bar oil reservoir is filled with
manufacturer recommended oil no motor
oil please finally check that the fuel
mixture is to manufacture specifications
usually a 50 to 1 race kit just ensure
you are wearing the following personal
protective equipment or PPE as it could
very well save your life wear sturdy
boots and Chainsaw chaps more than 40
percent of injuries occur on the left
leg or foot this alone could prevent an
injury also make sure to wear a hard hat
to protect your head from falling
objects that might be dislodged from the
tree fees you're working on don't forget
your hearing protection chainsaws are
loud and we want to be able to hear our
children or grandchildren put on your
safety glasses chainsaws kick up debris
that can easily scratch your eyes and
damage your vision finally gloves are
highly recommended and should always be
worn when sharpening the Chainsaw for
more safety tips and instructional
videos visit the Alabama extension
website at
www.aces.edu to keep you safe next time
you start that chainsaw